et mon dieu
[Musique]
6h du matin calcutta footing pour une
quinzaine de jeunes boxeurs qui doivent
se frayer un chemin entre les voitures
les échoppes et les passants en tête
radiale la première femme indienne
coaches et arbitres internationale la
mousson se fait attendre il fait déjà 50
degrés malgré la chaleur les coureurs
parcourent une dizaine de kilomètres
toujours au même rythme soutenu ce n'est
que la première étape de leur
entraînement qui va durer six heures en
inde
la boxe c'est le criquet dépôt quand on
boxe on doit s'habituer à boxer dans
n'importe quelles conditions et dans
n'importe quel environnement
parce qu'on ne sait jamais ce qui va se
passer dans les championnats c'est pour
ça qu'on s'entraîne dans des conditions
extrêmes parmi les élèves de radia une
dizaine de filles entre 7 et 22 en inde
ou musulmanes ou autre elle brise les
tabous d'une société indienne qui malgré
des lois en leur faveur leur laisse peu
de place pour s'émanciper
la plupart des filles viennent des
bidonvilles de calcutta et espère avec
le sport se forger une identité en tant
que femme et sortir de la misère à
calcutta
on est plus progressiste que dans les
autres états indiens les 25 ans de
gestion communiste ont couvert les
esprits mais la mixité et les tenues de
sport moulante suscite toujours autant
d'interrogations parmi le public on
s'entraîne ici sur la place au milieu de
la foule j'aime ça parce que les gens
nous regardent et on sent dans leur
regard leur envie qu'un jour on devient
des championnes et ça ça me motive
[Musique]
où
à peine le temps de se remettre les
filles enchaînent avec le sac
à partir de maintenant c'est à zip qui
prend la relève
cet ancien boxeur devenu président de la
ligue amateur de boxe et le premier à
avoir ouvert son ring aux filles il y a
trois ans aziz perçoit des subventions
du gouvernement et de la municipalité
mais il doit aussi mettre de sa poche
pour permettre aux filles de boxer pour
shakila et shine ou 17 ans aucun répit
ces jumelles sont les deux espoirs
d'asie ses inséparables sont les plus
assidus et plus motivés les plus
ambitieuses de son club
elle se donne à fond à chaque
entraînement surtout à l approche du
tournoi qui aura lieu dans quelques
jours au club
[Applaudissements]
moi je m'entraîne beaucoup
d'entraînement ce qui est important
c'est de se donner à fond et surtout de
bien respirer
shakira est chez nous comme les autres
fils du club ont très peu d'espoir de
s'en sortir à travers les études réussir
à intégrer l'équipe nationale de boxe
c'est pour elles l'assurance d'avoir un
job dans la police l'armée ou
l'administration
en inde les sportifs de renom font
partie du patrimoine national et ont
accès à de nombreux emplois travers la
boxe les filles rêvent d'avoir une place
dans la société et de se forger une
identité
elles veulent acquérir une certaine
sécurité une sécurité financière qui
leur permettrait d'avoir une vie plus
confortable plus tard une fois qu'elles
auront atteint ses objectifs
elles verront plus loin elle rêve rondes
au championnat du monde et de gloire est
salée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fait remonter les filles sur le ring n'a
pas été facile pour has it
il a dû combattre les craintes des
familles que leur fille soit défiguré
ruine ainsi toute perspective de mariage
[Musique]
on l'a souvent accusés de pervertir les
filles au début j'ai eu des problèmes
parce que beaucoup de gens pensaient que
les fils n'avait pas les qualités pour
boxer
pour les petits pas de capacité
d'encaisser de donner des coups mais
selon la philosophie indienne
une femme est huit fois plus fort qu'un
homme physiquement mentalement
psychologiquement elles doivent
affronter tous les problèmes de la
maison et de la vie à commencer par le
bébé jusqu'au mari sur le pilier de la
famille ado non je ne sais pas si elles
vont devenir des championnes mais je
suis certain d'une chose seront à
l'avenir des femmes fortes
rml équilibré retour à la maison pour
chaque île à échelle où les jumelles
boxe depuis l'âge de 5 ans depuis
qu'elles ont vu les garçons du quartier
s'entraîner
une véritable passion que leur mère a
toujours encouragé leurs tenues peu
traditionnelle ne la dérange pas bien au
contraire
hazard est assistante sociale son
quotidien est fait de rencontres avec
des femmes battues c'est pour cela
qu'elle pousse ses filles a gagné leur
indépendance
chez elle ses fils et ses filles sont
traités sur le même pied d'égalité
mes deux filles sont les tigresses
elles sont très forts physiquement et
mentalement et en plus elles sont
intelligentes
je pense que les filles peuvent être
très forte grâce à leur volonté et
qu'elle peut même être meilleur que des
hommes
shakila et chan ou ont déjà un beau
palmarès au niveau local et national
mais elle ne compte pas s'arrêter là au
dernier tournoi moi j'ai gagné la
médaille d'argent et ma soeur a gagné
l'or toutes les deux on va encore
progresser
on veut aller jusqu'au niveau national
et participer au championnat du mois je
ne serais pas là toute leur vie pour
notre pays
leur père aimant mais je suis sûr
qu'elles vont s'en sortir
à peine le temps de se changer de se
désaltérer les jumelles fil à leurs
cours d'anglais une heure quotidienne
donné gratuitement paris acenta une amie
de la famille fans les deux boxeuses le
cours ne semble pas perturber la sieste
du mari de ja centa les jumelles me
disent qu'elles voient les autres
boxeuse voyager partout et être à l'aise
mais elle comme elle ne parle pas
anglais
elles ne peuvent pas répondre on y au
coach ni aux professeurs ni aux
journalistes
elle me répète que quand elle regarde la
télé elle voit des cirrus défi chinoise
qui savent parler anglais
elle se demande pourquoi pas elle
chamakh ou la boxe les études c'est
aussi très important pour moi
[Musique]
salah jusqu'à 10 go la haye love to
study in love to the stars fall in stat
et 28 c'est une bonne élève tisot xvi
c'est une très bonne élève elle fait
beaucoup d'efforts pour yann gré
radhia maîtrise l'anglais et a eu la
chance de poursuivre ses études
universitaires
mais sa passion c'était la boxe et elle
en a fait son métier
à ses débuts elle a dû se battre pour
que la communauté musulmane dont elle
est issue accepte son choix elle allait
au club voile est puni fille qui boxait
c'était une fille déshonoré déshonoré
cela signifie que la femme ne fait plus
partie de la communauté religieuse et
civile
cela veut dire qu'elle n'a pas suivi les
préceptes religieux et qu'elle ne
trouvera ni mari ni belle famille
personne ne voudra d'elle comme femme
comme belle-fille même si elles n'ont
vie parade ya fait une belle carrière et
a pu trouver un mari et une belle
famille qui l'acceptent telle qu'elle
est aujourd'hui elle rend visite à son
père il est plutôt traditionaliste
mais c'est grâce à lui qu'elle a pu
boxer il l'a défendu a su imposer le
choix de sa fille dans la communauté
quel sens a indiqué à l'époque tout le
monde était contre l'âme mais moi
j'avais confiance
j'étais convaincu qu'un jour ou l'autre
mais choix serait acceptée en autorisons
une femme à boxer on est allé contre
toutes les traditions de la société
c'était notre djihad il est 16 heures
radhia vient chercher ses filles pour
l'entraînement de l'après midi son
chemin il rencontre al ahmar à une autre
admiratrice de radia qui voit en elle un
modèle à suivre
mais al amara qui continue ses études
s'entraîne moins que les jumelles
m
je suis fier parce que j'ai réussi à
entraîner et former des filles comme
elle et ça c'était mon objectif
es tu un modèle pour elle sam je ne sais
pas si on peut vraiment parler de modèle
je suis leur coach leurs professeurs
parfois je suis une mère pour elle mais
aussi une amie une soeur et même un père
quand on nous accoste dans la rue je
dois me battre comme si c'étaient mes
filles se rendre au club n'est pas donné
il est à huit stations de tramway et le
ticket coûte cher sans compter qu'il
faut aussi acheté la tenue short
tee-shirt gang band et chaud sur un
trajet seul ce n'est pas trop cher mais
au bout d'un mois ça commence à compter
par exemple aujourd'hui on va prendre le
train ou trois ou quatre fois et là ça
devient cher pour l éternel c'est fatal
[Musique]
arrivé au club chaque entraînement
démarre par le même rituel hindou de la
prière je voulais surtout avant de
commencer la journée le matin avant les
examens quand on va à l'école ont pris
pour les choses qui nous tiennent à
coeur
et comme la boxe c'est important dans
notre vie ont pris avant de boxer on a
vu que dieu pour qu'il soit avec nôtre
et nous rendre plus performant à
l'entraînement va durer trois heures
presque sans aucun répit sac ring
étirements la chaleur est insoutenable
même quand le soleil décline
mais les filles tiennent bon le tournoi
approche al amara elle a du mal à suivre
son embonpoint avec un handicap
mon rêve c'est de devenir une très belle
mais une très grande boxeuse
c'est un défi je veux progresser réussir
et il montre à mes parents que j'ai fait
le bon choix
sur le chemin du retour à la mara rend
visite à son père vendeur de samosas est
cuisinier quand il en a l'occasion
une situation précaire pour toute la
famille qui espère qu'en réussissant à
la mara pour aller faire vivre à leur
offrir un avenir meilleur je suis très
pauvre mes parents sont décédés il ya
longtemps je loue un petit appartement
dans ce quartier mal famé et je suis
content que ma fille box elle va
peut-être nous sortir de là mais pour
réaliser son rêve être plus combative al
amara doit perdre quelques kilos moi je
ne peux pas manger c'est çà mau ça parce
que j'ai un problème de poids
et si j'en mange ça va empirer si je
suis trop grosse sera impossible pour
moi de boxer et de gagner des tournois
[Musique]
al amara habite à quelques pas
ils sont six à y vivre et à partager
deux petites pièces la cuisine ou à
l'amarrage change sert aussi de salle de
bains dans cette armoire à la mara garde
précieusement la photo de laila ali la
fille du célèbre mohamed ali elle
regarde ces matchs dès qu'elle peut
avoir accès à une télévision al amara
caresse le rêve de pouvoir un jour
devenir aussi championne de boxe je
laime beaucoup c'est mon idole sauf que
je veux vraiment lui ressemble et palmer
elle sait que ça va être très difficile
mais avec beaucoup de volonté et un peu
de chance je vais y arriver
je suis très fier d'avoir ma faute et
dans les journaux
moi aussi j'en viens jouer d'être celle
mg avait peut-être en m'entraînant bout
le père d'al hamara est de retour avec
la recette de la journée
aujourd'hui il a gagné 300 roupies soit
6 euros 200 seront réinvestis pour
préparer les samossas il lui reste à
peine de quoi faire vivre sa famille al
amara et sa mère prépare le dîner dans
le noir sans eau courante ni électricité
une ampoule coupe 15 roupies un vrai
luxe qu'elles ne peuvent pas se
permettre
nicolai gedda stocker les jeux place
tous mes espoirs sur azilda nergie
l'entraîneur d'al hamara d'escalier il
va trouver un moyen de la sortir de là
et de lui trouver un job
on va se serrer la ceinture pour elle on
économise sur le budget de la maison
pour pouvoir payer ses vêtements et ses
déplacements et on espère que ça va nous
rapporter quelque chose dont le quartier
d'autres familles vivent encore plus
pauvrement leurs priorités survivre et
marier leur fille pour avoir une bouche
de moins à nourrir la boxe est un loisir
qui ne peuvent pas s'offrir asic se rend
avec alam arraché par bean une ancienne
boxeuse très talentueuse elle a arrêté à
cause de son père les enfants affamés
boxe au mieux ils sont plus motivés
parce que ce n'est pas seulement un
combat sur le ring c'est aussi un combat
pour leur survie
il y un champion de boxe qui viennent ce
quartier s'appelle mohamed ali camara il
a sorti ce quartier de la misère et un
donner un sens à la communauté qui sait
peut-être qu'une autre million dollar
baby sortira d'ici et elle sera une
source d'inspiration pour qu'elle put
ipod pays et
[Applaudissements]
son frère est à l'hôpital son père au
chômage et ses six frères et soeurs
peinent à se nourrir
darvin dû renoncer à la boxe pour aider
sa mère c'est son rêve qui s'est brisée
j'ai quitté la boxe parce que mon père a
perdu son travail il ya huit mois
je ne pouvais plus payer le transport et
les vêtements on avait plus assez
d'argent pour manger
c'est pour ça que j'ai dû abandonner la
boxe peine perdue has it ne fait pas le
poids contre la misère est libre je ne
peux pas promettre de miracle je peux
ouvrir la voie et montrer le chemin si
la famille est motivée elle soutiendra
et encouragera la boxeuse
mais je ne veux surtout pas donner de
faux espoirs à quiconque je veux juste
montrer le chemin et proposer de
nouveaux horizons
le tournoi a lieu dans quelques heures
c'est un événement pour résister pour
les filles les tournois sont rares ils
sont difficiles et cher a organisé pour
l'occasion tout le monde met la main à
la pâte y compris les boxeuses radia
troqué sa tenue de coach pour celle
d'arbitré international
je suis très fier parce que c'est la
première fois que notre club organise un
tournoi en l'honneur de pierre roj
c'est le père de la boxe indienne je
suis vraiment fier et je suis fier aussi
de faire partie de ce club
chez nous et chatila sont très détendus
elles sont accompagnées de leurs deux
plus grandes admiratrices leur mère et
yassen état depuis cinq heures du matin
elles n'ont qu'une obsession mettre ko
leurs adversaires on est toutes les deux
très fortes on est les meilleurs et
aucune fille ne peut nourrir nos
adversaires ont intérêt à bien réfléchir
avant de monter sur le ring
parce qu'on va tout les sites raser les
mettre ko en tout cas ça notre objectif
on va gagner c'est sûr on va même jouer
à l'étranger et gagner on va gagner
toutes les deux ensemble
on n'a pas peur on va jouer avec le
physique et la rage de certains
adversaires font leur entrée
malgré la chaleur et la demi-journée de
transport et affiche une assurance et
une sérénité qui va en déstabiliser plus
d'une razzia profitent des derniers
instants pour donner ses instructions à
ses filles
ma recommandation boxer avec la tête
pas seulement avec les poings sur le
ring les combats ont condensé de file
des sites ont été mise ko le rendent
d'al hamara approche elle perd ses
moyens
dans les vestiaires les inséparables
affiche toujours la même sérénité
chanoux coach sa soeur elle élabore pour
elle une stratégie d'attaqué
en inde
ce n'est pas vraiment la technique qui
compte mais bien plus la rage de vaincre
c'est ce qui a permis aux boks aux
indiennes de se hisser au quatrième rang
mondial
c'est al amara de faire son entrée sur
le ring elle a trois rounds de 2 minutes
30 pour aligner son adversaire dès le
départ les coups pleuvent à la mara ne
fait pas le poids
sa mère l'a soutien tant qu'elle peut et
veut encore croire à sa victoire
je suis très heureuse et je le serai
encore plus si elle gagne je n'ai pas
peur qu'à se prennent un mauvais coup
sinon je l'aurais pas laisser monter sur
le ring fin du premier round
al ahmar a été puisé ses fans et c'est
de lui remonter le moral
[Applaudissements]
en coulisses les jumelles s'échauffent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fin de combat pour al amara c'est la
défaite
[Applaudissements]
elle quitte le ring déçu sans un regard
ni un mot pour ça mais je suis déçu je
n'ai pas pu m'entraîner à c'est à cause
de mes examens j'ai besoin de plus
d'entraînement
[Musique]
chaque il a fait son entrée sur le ring
la tigresse suit les conseils de sa
soeur et assène coup sur coup à son
adversaire mais rien à faire l'autre
résiste et ne se laissent pas mettre ko
chan où se précipitent pour la coacher
chat qui la reprend le dessus et frappe
de plus en plus fort en coinçant son
adversaire une belle victoire
ici on ne gagne pas de trophée
ce qui compte c'est se confronter à
d'autres adversaires et progresser pour
monter en division 1 boxe féminine c'est
plus dur d'organiser des tournois parce
qu'il n'ya pas assez de participantes
il nous faudrait plus de boxeuse pour
avoir plus d'argent oui pour avoir plus
de financement et de sponsors et laon
pour en effet les envoyer dans des
tournois dans des états voisins
les frères venus les entraîner les faire
participer à d'autres tournois
c'est ça l'objectif
on
pour chan ou le match était gagné
d'avancé
son mental de fer et sa rage de vaincre
ont eu raison de son adversaire pourtant
plus forte techniquement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais pour les deux soeurs leur plus
grande joie c'est d'avoir remporté
ensemble le tournoi j'ai les larmes aux
yeux mais ce sont des larmes de joie en
t on a gagné toutes les deux
elle est vraiment les meilleurs de notre
club et on a même battu les filles de
l'extérieur azita de quoi être fier de
ses tigresses
mais pour qu'elles deviennent des
championnes il va falloir qu'il organise
d'autres tournois pour qu'elles soient
repérés par un entraîneur de l'équipe
nationale
maintenant j'ai plus de responsabilités
je dois les amener plus loin si elle
avait perdu le tournoi on aurait
continué à s'entraîner normalement
mais là je dois les pousser les
perfectionner encore plus
quelle est la prochaine étape plus
d'entraînement de meilleur entraînement
pour qu'elles atteignent la perfection
[Musique]
avec leurs poings razzia les jumelles al
amara et les autres soeurs du ring ont
ouvert la voie vers plus d'égalité pour
les femmes mais il reste encore beaucoup
de combats à gagner pour leur véritable
émancipation
[Musique]